hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his work on
fate where Cicero is considering a
fundamental metaphysical question about
whether the human being has any degree
of freedom or whether everything is
determined by some sort of necessity or
fate one of the key thinkers that he's
going to examine at considerable length
is cruciferous and cruciferous was the
third skull arc of the stoic school very
important school at the time that Cicero
was writing one that's had a lot of
influence down through history and the
Stoics had a very interesting
perspective on this question of freedom
and necessity unlike some others who
would be willing to say that everything
is totally determined there's nothing
you can do nothing is up to you you have
no choices so don't worry about any of
that would be the determinism or
fatalism side and unlike others who said
oh no there's complete human freedom you
can escape the bounds of necessity there
may be some things that are necessitated
but nothing that really applies to human
minds or choices or actions the stoic
said it's actually both
and so this is what in the discussion of
free will and determinism we call
compatibilism and Cicero in what he's
giving us of cruciferous here is
articulating one of the many
compatibilist positions that we find
throughout the history of ideas and so
when you're a compatible list you're
actually in some respect trying to
proverbial have-your-cake-
and-eat-it-too
which by the way you can do you can
actually have a cake and eat it right
there's no problem with that in most
circumstances but they're trying to have
a determinism where everything is fated
or as Cicero is going to have
precipitous talk about following the
conventions of his time everything
happens of necessity or fate in some
respect every proposition about what
occurs is either true or false including
ones about the future he wants to have
that and at the same time he wants to
have some degree of freedom freedom of
what freedom of the body no freedom of
the human mind and Cicero actually tells
us that he regards cruciferous as being
in this kind of middle position he says
that cruciferous stood is an unofficial
umpire and wished to strike a compromise
as a matter of fact he inclines to
adhere to those who held that the mind
is released from all necessity of motion
that is the mind can determine itself
there are some things that are
volitional that are our own choice but
Cicero also points out because of the
formulas because of the language that he
used that's peculiar to himself he slips
into difficulties that against his will
he lends support to the necessity of
fate so let's take a look now at what
Cicero provides us of cruciferous
doctrines here we should mention too
that we don't actually possess any
writings by cruciferous as such but
there are fragments and portions of his
works not only in Cicero but in several
other philosophers as well so as a stoic
as somebody who believes that everything
is material and that there is a kind of
ruling logos running through things
cruciferous argues that all motion all
change everything that is the way it is
and everything that's going to be
different is caused is caused by
precedent or antecedent causes that is
things that happen before it lead to
things coming after it and if you put
all these together in some sort of
causal Nexus then you can say that
everything is happening by fate and this
is something that cruciferous is
committed to and the Stoics in general
are committed to he goes a little bit
further in saying that everything arises
and here he's using the word eternal in
a somewhat different manner perhaps then
later philosophers will do meaning from
eternity causes that have always been
and and you know in some respect will
always have an influence so internal
causes governing future events
everything unrolls
in this succession where cause leads to
effect that effect leads to other causes
and so on and so on and so on
so we have a deterministic universe that
we belong to a determined universe
seemingly in every single respect now
how do we get any freedom out of this
this is where we have to make some
important distinctions and that is
precisely one of the things that
cruciferous did that is a contribution
to this idea or debate or understanding
and that's part of what Cicero is
highlighting here so there are some
distinctions and some clarifications
about the notion of cause in the
strictest sense we should only use the
word
for what makes the effect come about
right what produces the effect and
Cicero says that it's not just enough to
proceed to be before the effect it has
to precede it effectively the word there
is a faqih inter coming from the word to
create or to bring about or to produce
saucony right so the cause has to in a
certain respect produce the effect it's
not enough that it contributes to it
it's not enough that it's just they're
doing something in the background it has
to really be central to this a little
bit later Cicero is going to discuss
what we could call necessary conditions
and this is particularly important as
well as says they declare and you means
the Stoics that there is a difference
whether a thing the thing that we're
considering as a cause is of such a kind
that something cannot be effected
without it so what we're talking about
there is something being a necessary
condition for something else so if we
think about he's not using this as an
example but if we think about an example
of going out and fishing with worms and
a hook you know you you don't
necessarily have to have a rowboat but
you could be in a rowboat out in the
middle of the lake or you could cast
from the shore the hook is the cause in
a certain respect of the fish being
caught right but if you throw the hook
out by itself unless you have a really
stupid fish or very hungry right if
they're defeating frenzied it's not
gonna bite a bare hook by itself you
need to put some bait on the hook and
then you could come up with other things
we could create lures or you go on all
sorts of other examples with respect to
fishing but just imagine putting a worm
on the hook in the old-fashioned manner
of
of fishing right the worm is what the
fish actually sees gravitates towards
bites down on the hook then penetrates
them to its mouth and then you reel it
in or perhaps pull it in if there's no
real on your fishing rod which of those
is the cause well you do need the worm
but the worm is just a necessary
condition the worm doesn't cause in any
very strict sense the fish being caught
it's a matter of fact you could probably
point at each of the things and say you
know rod line hook worm not all those
are just necessary conditions none of
them are actually the single cause so he
says there's a difference between
whether a thing is of such a kind that
nothing cannot be affected without it or
such that nothing or that or such that
something must necessarily be affected
by it a cause necessitates the effect a
cause in the strict sense so perhaps the
hook you could say is the cause of the
fish being able to be reeled in in a
certain respect because it's hooked
through the flesh though the hook is the
cause of the damage to the fish right
and the worm is just a proximate cause
in that example so it's not just what's
necessary conditions for effects cícero
goes on and he says none of the causes I
mentioned is really a cause because none
by its own force affects the thing of
which it is said to be the cause nor is
that which is a condition other things
being affected a cause but that of which
the access necessarily produces the
thing of which it is the cause and going
back now to this notion of of cause and
the language that we're using
cruciferous is willing to allow us to
use the term provided we make an
important distinction
so some causes are perfect and
principal ruling right they actually do
bring about the effect others just make
some sort of contribution they're part
of the causal Nexus but they are not the
single thing that determines that he
calls those auxiliary that is helpful
you could say and proximate the
auxiliaries in the Roman army were the
people who weren't part of the legions
but fought on the side of it and you
know helped out they weren't to be
relied upon as the main principal thing
so we can distinguish between these
different kinds of causes where is the
upshot for this well we see this bearing
its fruit when we look at this famous
example of the cylinder or the top that
cruciferous used to try to explain the
compatibilist position about the human
mind and it's very important to remember
that this is an analogy this is not a
exact one-to-one correspondence he's not
saying we are a cylinder or we are a top
the human mind works differently but
there is a structural resemblance here
so what is the idea behind the cylinder
at the top you have a cylinder which is
round and it can roll down an incline or
you have a top which is a cone and you
spin it right you you or maybe you do it
with your fingers you set it spinning
which of those is the cause is pushing
the cylinder the cause of it rolling or
is it the nature of the cylinder itself
Chris tempest says that there's a very
important difference here you're just
adding a motion to it you are causing in
a certain sense but you're an auxilary
and proximate cause you're not the
principal cause for the cylinder rolling
the nature of the cylinder the fact that
it's round rather than square is why it
rolls and can
ten years rolling similarly with the top
you started spinning but then it
continues on its own motion which you
imparted to it but it does that because
of its nature you can't say spin a book
I mean you can try and maybe if you're
super lucky you find a surface on which
you could actually spin this but it's
not of that nature now the human mind
what about its desires its appetites and
its a sense the Stoics want to claim
that these are actually up to us or in
our power in in potus thought a is how
Cicero talks about it which is very
similar to the language that's used
later on by people like epictetus and
who mean up to us in our control so this
is a consistent doctrine the Stoics
wanted to say that desire to some degree
is within our power assent even more so
is yet desire can be caused by outside
things you see the fruit you're hungry
and you start to you know desire eating
that fruit you see a beautiful person of
whatever gender you're attracted to and
you feel sexual desire towards them now
desire is one thing and we feel it right
and when the Stoics also talk about a
version which is the sort of
corresponding thing away from desire you
know you see something gross maybe some
garbage and you're like I don't want to
touch that right or you get something
slimy on your hands and you want to go
and wash your hands
that's a desire a sin is something
further than that that is where you
yourself sort of take that on ratify it
make it your own and the Stoics thought
as many other philosophers do it's
possible to have a desire that comes to
you without you actually choosing it's
caused by something on the
although it's cause because of your
human nature as well and then you can
choose whether to assent to it or not
now if everything was fated by necessity
it would seem that you actually don't
have any choice about a scent
cruciferous says no you actually do have
choice about a scent but it is also
faded there are causes for it but you
yourself your human nature the mind that
you've created to some degree right
through your own working of yourself
through the choices you've made the
thoughts you've thought the willings
you've willed that is the cause for
whether you assent or not to this or
that desire so on the one hand you are
determined there is a quasi lexus but
you're part of that causal Nexus and
you've determined part of what that
causal Nexus looks like so you're also
in another respect free not greatly free
of course because you don't control
really anything outside of the
boundaries of your mind for the Stoics
but there is a certain sort of freedom
there and this is a compatibilist
position on the issue of freedom and
determinism some people may look at this
and say that really doesn't seem like
freedom to me so long as there is a
causal Nexus you're just talking about
us having a sort of extra role at the
end of all these other causes
but the Stoics and cruciferous really
did think that to some degree this does
at least as far as the mind goes lie
within our power so there is some
freedom there even though there is a
nexus of causes precisely because we
ourselves are one of those causes the
nature that we have and make for ourself
become in this case a perfect and
primary cause
you